shark week has begun and all week the  discovery channel is showing programming  that portrays sharks as ruthless killing  machines yeah but you know what i think  i think it seems so one-sided yeah you  know it's not fair to the shark so i  decided to offer my own shark based  programming highlighting a lighter more  positive side of sharks that's right  it's my tv shark tacular  [Applause]  it's fun  uh for today's shark tacular here's some  footage of sharks just hanging out and  having fun in the sun  enjoy  sharks  maybe nibble mr shark yum yum yum yum  pretty tea  i'll have a cheese  i love you mr shark  yay sharks  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]